at the age of 13 bitcoin is now well and
truly a teenager and as every parent
knows these are troublesome years
cryptocurrencies have established
themselves as viable investable assets
on the radar of traders around the globe
now comes the moment when they must find
their identity and assert their place in
portfolios everywhere
not too long ago it was easy to find
voices saying bitcoin was it worse to
scam
and at best a mass delusion which would
return to the intrinsic value of the
zeros and ones it's made of
that became harder last year as the
financial infrastructure left forward
these developments made the inflow of
institutional money possible
exchange-traded products mentioning
bitcoin in their description now contain
nearly 12 billion in holdings
in the u.s a pro-shares product that
launched in october now has more than a
billion dollars in assets aggregate open
interest on the cme's bitcoin futures
contract has trended higher since launch
such products will also eventually come
to other crypto assets like ethereum and
there's a good chance that these
alternative assets will move the future
of crypto into a new direction
that will create trouble and turmoil as
the battle for the heart of crypto rages
on
remember at its foundation bitcoin
represented 100 of the total market
value of cryptocurrencies
but with every year that passes that
percentage falls according to coin
market cap it now comprises just over 40
percent of the total value the fact then
is that crypto appears to have a bright
future
but exactly what that future looks like
no one can say for sure
i'm eddie van der walt this is decrypted
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms